and you gave to me
I'm gonna cry you gave me permission to
build a business loving people because I
believed you I have now made just under
10 million dollars since that time
and I love you thank you
Elizabeth congratulations let's clap it
up for Elizabeth
look I really believe what just happened
with Elizabeth and I so so so much for
her it was like hey I like having this
business but like me it feels even
better of what it's doing with the
people I'm working with or for whom or
who's buying my thing and like if that's
you then that's what you need to focus
on more than the p l or maximizing your
funnel stop chasing and start looking
inside
[Music]